hello there when he was Karen Gordon
from film courage my new show we're here
at the 10th annual firstly its own
festival bear in Hollywood and I have
the esteemed pleasure of speaking with
mr. Nick baisley Sabri hey everyone how
you doing nick has come out here to Los
Angeles and he's here for about a week
is that right 34 days yeah 34 days and
might I add I cannot believe I'm
standing here with mr. David Brandon and
ms karen worden of film courage and film
courage interactive well thank you thank
you it's our pleasure as well and we're
curious you're here in LA you want to
make a move out here right you're in
Massachusetts you eventually want to
come to Los Angeles what's this whole
kind of weekend been like for you it has
been it has been completely completely
crazy i I've just not had any downtime
at all and because I filled anytime down
time I've had with like weird touristy
stuff like I've been no I took the time
up to Griffith Observatory I got layout
of the whole land I walked up and down
Hollywood Boulevard and went to the
kodak theatre and brahms chinese leader
the egyptian and just kind of tried to
see get all the touristy stuff i think
out of my system so next time I come
here it's all business but no I can't
wait to come out here I've enjoyed the
the time we're here actually and the
rally Studios lot here right off of
Melrose I got to meet I actually got to
meet a couple of stars and I've just
I've been my time here has been so great
than people like yourselves have come
out and welcome me and I met other
people from Twitter and twitter.com /
from sorry I missed so many other people
and it's it's just been such a good time
and people been so warm and welcome I
one say thank you to Bill ostrov the
director of the first glance from
festival Hollywood for helping me get
out here as well to cover his festival
for him it was just been a great
experience meeting all these filmmakers
and being a part of the festival from
the back end and also you know reporting
on it and getting the word out it's been
great and aside from a good reserve of
security deposit and moving expenses and
all of that what do you think a
filmmaker or an artist in general that's
making that trek out to LA needs to come
armed with aside from the money which I
know is very important out here and
that's sort of the bottom line but once
you get past that what do you think a
lot of it's going to be ambition and
desire and and less talk and more walk
this is a you know it's also you need to
be outgoing it's a business of
relationships and you really need to get
involved in the industry if you want to
be a part of it you need to be inside of
it and you know even if it's the
independent film industry you have to
know you know what's going on in your
industry you have to be prepared you
know to make changes in your plans you
know at the drop of a dime if the
industry changes you know you have to
know that if you're going to make a
project out here you know do you have an
audience for that project if not show it
for a bit and start on something else
that might be a little bit more
commercial something that's a stepping
stone for you but just get involved out
here people there's so many wonderful
people out here that are willing to help
if you're just are nice enough and
willing to ask and maybe even just being
out here for a few days and you know
asking people to help me with this that
or the other thing they've been so
helpful in warm and welcome and greatly
greatly appreciate I think I found my
next production crew for the show if I
come out here here in the span of two
days so it's just been it's been great
and that's the advice I can really kind
of give to any any other independent
filmmakers come out here with a desire
to work and work hard and you know the
hard work pays off